guys I can't I can't breathe I'm like I'm on the top of some mountain and I have all I have is me and my altimeter and it says I'm super super super high and I'm I'd be really really nervous I am oh wait a minute I'm I'm at the top of the Beverly Center shopping mall nevermind welcome to smartlist wait first of all Jay tell us how it's going you're started your film yes I do good you don't want to hear boring work crap I appreciate you asking but I can I just thought about directing is that bug grabbed you yet he's coming with gas today let's buckle up yeah it's how's your work you're getting ready to start
伙计们 我不行 我透不过气来 我就像是 我在某座山顶上 而我身上所有的一切只有我和我的高度计 然后它显示我超级超级高 而我 我会真的真的很紧张 我是哦 等一会儿 我 我在贝弗利中心购物商场的屋顶上 算了吧 欢迎来到 SmartLess 等等 首先 杰伊 告诉我们进展如何 你开始拍电影了吗 是的 我做得很好 你不想听无聊的工作废话 我很感激你问我 但是 我能 刚才我只想到导演工作了 那个Bug抓到你了吗 他今天带着油来了 我们系好安全带吧 是的 你的工作怎么样 你准备开始
your rehearsals yes all right stop not for six months but listen I'm back to you for a second nice deflection back to you but I'm excited you're doing a movie with Taryn Edgerton right and what's it are you a fan it's called Harry on it started this week I saw I spent the day with Danny D's today okay let's talk sweet Pete Giles Danny D's and and our good friend what golfing Rob low yeah oh yeah hey guess what I tried pickleball for the first time did you yeah did you my neck is snapping all over the place let's just keep switching subjects oh wait a minute but did you play golf with them well yeah I sure did yeah so I
你的排练了吗 是的 好了 停下 不是六个月后 但听着 我一会儿再找你 漂亮的转移话题 回到你身上 但我很兴奋你要和泰伦·埃格顿拍电影 对吧 叫什么 你是粉丝吗 叫《哈里》 本周开拍了 我今天和丹尼·D度过了一天 好吧 让我们谈谈 甜心皮特·吉尔斯 丹尼·D 还有还有我们的好朋友 打高尔夫的罗伯·劳 是啊 哦 对了 嘿 你猜怎么着 我第一次尝试匹克球 你玩了吗 是啊 你玩了吗 我的脖子到处都在咔咔作响 我们还是继续换话题吧 哦 等一会儿 但你跟他们一起打高尔夫了吗 嗯 是的 我当然打了 是的 所以我
played pickleball I think at the same place you guys play golf probably not and they wouldn't dare oh really okay it's fun it is who'd you play with who'd you play with Kevin carry who you know oh yeah sure they're nice peeps and like Kevin carry yeah and our friend I just don't like the sound it makes I there's such a great sound to a tennis ball hitting a tennis racket right in the middle of the strings yeah but that wiffle ball hitting a wood it's I don't mean to sound like a purist a lot of communities on the east coast are now not letting people build pickleball courts at home because they're too loud huh
打匹克球 我想在你们打高尔夫的同一个地方 可能不是 他们也不敢 哦 真的 好吧 这很有趣 确实 你跟谁玩的 你跟谁玩了 凯文·凯利 你认识吗 哦 是啊 当然 都是好人 就像凯文·凯利一样 还有我们的朋友 我只是不喜欢它发出的声音 网球击中网球拍正中心时有一种那么棒的声音 对吧 没错 但那个塑料球击中木板 听起来 我不是故意听起来像个纯粹主义者 东海岸的很多社区现在都不让人们在家建匹克球场 因为它们太吵了 咦
they're too loud yeah it's just like hitting a wiffle ball pink now yeah speaking of speaking of noise pollution and the west coast versus east coast I hear that here on the west coast they are outlawing gas blowers for leaves that you can only use an electric one now is that what you're gonna use yeah I mean it's I just redid I just rebuilt the engine on on my last one but and you know gas is getting so expensive so this is gonna be good but I'll be upside down for a while okay good oh I miss her I was thinking about I was thinking about pros who hang around gas stations you've heard blow and gas and
太吵了 是啊 就像击打塑料球 乒 噢 是啊 说到 噪声污染 以及西海岸对阵东海岸 我听说在西海岸 他们正在取缔用汽油驱动的树叶吹风机 你现在只能用电动的了 这是你要用的吗 是啊 我的意思是 我刚刚重做 我刚刚重修了上一台机器的发动机 但是你知道 汽油变得越来越贵 所以这会很好 但我得倒贴一段时间 好吧 好的 哦 我想念她 我在想 我在想那些在加油站晃荡的职业老手 你听过吹气和
everything yeah listen you've got it you've got a Saturday record here and you got it and it's a 430 start late in the day everyone's a little punchy yeah but wait Jason so do you still you fly home every weekend from the shoot I do wow yeah doesn't that isn't that exhausting well no you sleep on the plane and you know the excitement and the love that you feel approaching your family supersedes any fatigue Sean sure sure and get ready how is that how is the flight it was good it was good do they serve a meal on that well no you gotta pay extra for that and if you want to if you want Wi-Fi or you want to
一切 是啊 听着 你这里有一场周六的录制 而且你有 而且是4点半开始 一天中比较晚的时候 每个人都有点迷迷糊糊 是啊 但等等 杰森 所以你还是每次拍戏完周末都飞回家吗 我是的 哇 是啊 难道这 不会觉得很累吗 嘛 不会 你在飞机上睡觉 并且你知道 接近家人时感受到的兴奋和爱 会压倒任何疲惫 肖恩 确实 确实 准备好 飞行体验怎么样 很好 很好 他们在上面提供餐食吗 嘛 没有 你得为那个额外付钱 如果你想 如果你想用Wi-Fi或者你想
watch a movie or something like that so what I do is I just bring on my sleep mask right and you've got a neck you've got a neck pillow I got a neck pillow that's got blinders on it too so it just sort of sends up a signal yeah please don't speak to me I've got I've got sleep issues Sean this I wanted to know right behind you is that's a television that's a television yeah yeah and that's your desk in your office right at your home office yes mm-hmm so what's the point because I was podcasting off my dining room table don't say podcasting I was doing this it's not a verb okay here you go ready oh here we
看电影或诸如此类的事 所以我做的就是 我只带上我的眼罩 对吧 你有一个颈枕 你有一个带眼罩的颈枕 所以它差不多会发出一个信号  হ্যাঁ 请不要跟我说话 肖恩 我有睡眠问题 我想知道你身后的那个 是个电视机 那是个电视机 是的 是的 那是你家里的办公桌 对吧 在你的家庭办公室里 是的 嗯嗯 所以重点是什么 因为我以前是在饭厅的桌子上做播客 别说做播客 我在做这个 它不是个动词 好吧 给你 准备好了 哦 来了
go no you need to start why are you letting I'm just saying that that TV I mean it's pointed at the back of your head well I would turn around I'm on a swivel chair I would turn around or I would sit on the couch behind me that you can't see it's never happened it happened what it happened once and having one well why aren't you wearing white what happened usually well because you know I wear white often when we do them in the morning I wear like a long sleeve white t-shirt around the house and to bed and stuff you know that you know why do you wear long sleeves because I wear a long sleeve t-shirt
来了 不 你需要开始 为什么你让 我只是说那个电视机 我的意思是它正对着你的后脑勺 嗯 我会转过去 我坐的是旋转椅 我会转过去 或者我会坐在你看不见的我身后的沙发上 从来没发生过 发生过 什么 发生过一次 发生过一次 嘛 你为什么不穿白色的 发生过 通常 嘛 因为你知道 当我们早上做节目时我经常穿白色的 我在家里和睡觉时会穿件长袖白T恤之类 你知道的 为什么你要穿长袖 因为我穿长袖T恤
because that's a new thing it's like the last 18 months because my room to be very cold but I don't want to have this sheet the covers on me you don't want your elbows to get chilly yeah hey Sean hang on listen what's in your cue to tap in on the conversation I found somebody that I that gets that yeah so that's exactly right it's a new thing I'm learning all these things like I feel like I'm I'm firmly getting older because I'm like yeah I'm happy with this yeah I'm happy doing it like this this is the way I like to do it now you're talking to guys who are wearing pajamas for the last I know I know I can't believe that
因为那是件新鲜事 就像过去18个月一样 因为我的房间会很冷 但我不想身上盖着床单 你不希望你的肘部着凉 是啊 嘿 肖恩 等一下 听着 你有什么准备插话的内容 我找到了一个能够理解这一点的人 对吧 所以完全正确 这是一件新鲜事 我正在了解所有这些事情 就像我觉得我 正在坚定地变老 因为我想 是的 我对这个很满意 是啊 我很高兴能这样 我现在喜欢这样做了 你现在正在跟一群过去 一直穿着睡衣的人讲话 我知道 我知道 我真不敢相信
you would pass judgment on anybody yeah I'm not it's not past judgment I'm wondering if I can welcome you into my you know what I've got on now because we've entered fall I'm now well this is this is basically this they're the flannel pants yeah and I've got now I've got my berks on and socks yeah you're in no position no I was just I was wondering if I can welcome you to granddad land yet I guess I'm wearing it but I was out so I'm not wearing white because I just like I said I just got back from playing golf I wasn't looking for four minutes on this okay wait let's go let's go wait I don't let's go
你会对任何人评头论足 是啊 我没有 这不是评头论足 我在想我能不能欢迎你加入我的 你知道我现在穿的是什么吗 因为我们已经进入秋天 我现在 好了 这基本上是 这个 它们是法兰绒裤子 是啊 我现在已经穿上我的勃肯鞋和袜子了 是啊 你没有资格 不 我只是 我在想我能不能欢迎你进入爷爷的世界了 我想我是在穿着它 但我当时在外面 所以我没穿白色 因为就像我说的 我刚打完高尔夫球回来 我可不想在这个上面花四分钟 好吧 等等 我们走 我们走 等等 我不要 我们走
here we go all right let's start podcasting right we got it we got our set up but now we're podcasting let's get podcasting okay come on ready here we go come on okay I'm super excited you guys this this one's big today oh fuck sorry did I fucking be your opening line I keep all no it's big excited this is big I'm super excited this guy I want to pick this guy's brain he's been on my smart list list since the day we started he's also been on my personal list of people I've always wanted to meet and work with since I was a teenager Contravolta will he's from your homeland which means he's nice and probably ice
这就对了 好了 我们开始录音吧 我们弄好了我们的设备 但现在我们在录音 让我们开始录音吧 好吧 来吧 准备好了 我们走 来吧 好吧 我超级兴奋 你们 今天的这个很大哦 操 抱歉 我他妈的是不是把你的开场白抢了 我一直 不 不是很大 很兴奋 这个很大 我超级兴奋 这个家伙 我想探究一下这个家伙的脑子 自从我们开始以来 他就一直在我的SmartList名单上 自从我十几家伙以来 他也一直在我想见并合作的人的个人名单上 昆·特拉沃塔 他来自你的祖国 这意味着他很好 而且可能会溜
skates let's see guys we're dealing with a major player here in Hollywood so a holdoff on all his credits because you'd get you'd guess in two seconds I'll just say he worked as a janitor before making him in the film industry he also lived in his car while creating a very famous film he loves the ocean so much that he built his own submarine and he may have written dialogue such as I'll be back from his car he's responsible for directing two of the three highest grossing films of all time Cameron it's the brilliant James Cameron what's up guys this is a mistake what's up guys I'm gonna put my glasses on so I can see
冰 让我们看看 伙计们 我们在跟好莱坞的一个大人物打交道 所以先别提他的所有作品 因为你两秒钟就能猜出来 我只想说他在进入电影行业之前曾做过看门人 他还在创作一部非常著名的电影时住在自己的车里 他太热爱海洋了以至于自己造了一艘潜水员 并且他可能写过诸如“我还会回来的”之类的台词 甚至在车里写出来的 他负责导演了有史以来票房最高的电影中的两部 詹姆斯·卡梅隆 怎么了 伙计们 这是一个错误 怎么了 伙计们 我要把眼镜戴上 这样我才能看到
who's talking wait that really doesn't matter yeah that did that did shit that didn't help at all it doesn't matter hey can we swear on this thing yeah are you kidding me do we just beat it out later good no James Cameron you really have been on my smart list list since the date we started you've been a part of my nerd childhood from Terminator to Aliens to the abyss which is one of my favorite movies Titanic of course and now my adult nerd nerd adulthood with Avatar in the 17 sequels so thank you for being on today this is huge for us I've just been a massive massive fan from my whole life well thank you welcome
是谁在说话 等等 那真的没有关系 是啊 那确实 那确实 帮不上忙 一点用也没有 没关系 嘿 我们能在节目里说脏话吗 是啊 你开什么玩笑 我们稍后不能把它哔掉吗 好吧 不 詹姆斯·卡梅隆 自从我们开始以来 你真的就在我的SmartList名单上 从《终结者》到《异形》再到《深渊》（这是我最喜欢的电影之一） 还有《泰坦尼克号》 当然了 还有现在我的成年极客时期推出的《阿凡达》以及随后的17部续集 所以谢谢你今天能来 这对我们来说意义重大 我一辈子都是你的超级超级粉丝 不客气 欢迎
to to welcome to podcasting thank you yeah yeah I've never done it before it seems pretty straightforward you just sit around and and drizzle on about inconsequential bullshit I got it I got it okay it's kind of like directing right yeah exactly a little bit except not at all you look very healthy and rested for a guy who's been doing the some of the toughest work the town has to offer for the last 30 years yeah yeah we're in the home stretch of five years of continuous production right now yes Sigourney was just on and oh cool about that and remind me you're not shooting all five avatars at the same time
来到 欢迎来到播客 谢谢你 是啊 是啊 我从来没做过这个 看起来挺简单的 你就坐在那儿 喋喋不休地聊着那些无关紧要的废话 我懂了 我懂了 好吧 有点像当导演 对吧 是啊 确实 有点像 但又完全不是 作为一个在过去30年里一直在做这个镇上能提供的最艰难工作的家伙 你看起来非常健康和精神焕发 是啊 是啊 我们现在正处于连续五年制作的最后冲刺阶段 是的 西格妮刚刚来过 噢 聊得很酷 提醒我一下 你不是同时拍摄所有的五部《阿凡达》吧
correct now the thinking was to be semi sane and shoot the first couple and then if that actually worked finish them out but it's also we have a young cast and they would have aged out of their characters if we had waited to kind of just do them a couple years apart right so we shot all their bit well but with the you're talking to a real moron here but the because it can't stand but it's Jason talking if he if he or she starts to age out can't you kind of offset that a bit with some of the computer manipulation that you're doing anyway with their faces or no you're at 100% right except that I've got one young
对吧 现在我们的想法是保持半清醒状态 先拍前几部 如果这真的行得通 就把它们拍完 但同时 我们有一群年轻演员 如果我们等上几年才拍的话 他们的年龄就会超出他们扮演的角色所需要的年纪 对吧 所以我们拍完了他们所有的部分 哎 但是呢 你在跟一个真正的笨蛋说话 既然不能忍受 但这是杰森在说话 如果他或她开始变老了 你难道不能用你无论如何都在对他们的脸进行的一些电脑处理来稍微弥补一下吗 还是说不能 你100%说得对 除了我有一个年轻
young character who's supposed to be 15 16 in the story and he's a human kid who's in with the Navi kids and we shoot him photographically but you're right some of the Navi kids they could come back at 22 23 and still do their 17 year old character because the character doesn't age unless we age the characters right yes yes it's fascinating your brain is fascinating okay so try living in it yeah I do your Canadian that's you learn a little something every day so I wanted to get into your Toronto right I'm from Toronto where you from yeah Chippewa Niagara Falls oh fantastic okay so very close yeah how
年轻的角色 在故事里他应该是15、16岁 这是一个跟纳美人的孩子混在一起的人类小孩 我们是从摄影角度拍摄他的 但你是对的 有些纳美人的孩子 即使他们在22、23岁时回来 依然可以扮演他们17岁的角色 因为这个角色不会变老 除非我们让角色变老 对的 是的 太迷人了 你的脑子太迷人了 好吧 那你试着活在里面看看吧 是啊 我会的 你是加拿大人 真是活到老学到老 所以我想聊聊你的多伦多 我来自多伦多 你来自哪儿 是啊 齐帕瓦 尼亚加拉大瀑布 哦 太棒了 好吧 非常近 是啊 你
long what year did you sort of move from Canada do you leave Canada I live with my parents at 71 I was 17 and rocked up in Orange County then later obviously moved down to LA proper and you know that was 47 years ago 48 years ago do you feel any connection anymore to Canada in that way or yeah yeah you do yeah we have we have a couple of businesses in Saskatchewan so I mostly get back to Canada to work on that stuff like running booze or what yeah right we grow we grow yellow peas and fava beans and lentils and we do plant-based protein we built a factory there for plant-based protein so so why me do this so you're
什么时候 从加拿大搬出来的 你是什么时候离开加拿大的 我17岁时跟我父母住在一起 我17岁 然后去了奥兰治县 然后显然搬到了洛杉矶市区 那是47年前 48年前 你对加拿大还有那种归属感吗 或者 是的 是的 你会有 是啊 我们在萨斯喀彻温省有几家企业 所以我大部分时间回加拿大是为了处理那些事情 比如走私酒什么的 是啊 对的 我们种植 黄豌豆、蚕豆和小扁豆 我们做植物性蛋白 我们在那里建立了一家植物性蛋白工厂 所以 为什么我会做这个 所以你
you're you're a young guy who grew up in in the Niagara Falls area so that's not that's not New York that's not Buffalo it's close to it there's a good Niagara Falls and a bad Niagara Falls the good one just happens to be in Canada that's right I got it so there's plenty of falls to go around you should learn some stuff but so you know so you're there so you grew up in Ontario near Niagara Falls Ontario how at when you were a young man living there did you have aspirations to be a director at that time was there something that grabbed you and said I want to do this when you were living there yeah I like movies and
你是个在尼亚加拉大瀑布地区长大的年轻人 所以那不是 那不是纽约 那不是布法罗 离那儿很近 有一个好的尼亚加拉大瀑布和一个坏的尼亚加拉大瀑布 好的那个刚好在加拿大 对的 我明白了 所以到处都是瀑布 你应该学点东西 但是呢 所以 你知道 所以你在那儿 所以你在安大略省尼亚加拉大瀑布附近长大 当你是一个住在那里的年轻时 你当时有当导演的志向吗 有什么东西吸引着你 并对你说“我想做这个” 当你住在那里的时候 是的 我喜欢电影
I was making little films just with a super 8 camera stuff like that but the idea that I could actually go and do it for real was so alien and bizarre it never really occurred to me but when my my parents asked me if I wanted to move to Los Angeles because my dad had gotten the opportunity to do a transfer there I said isn't that near Hollywood and my my mom my mom said well we're not really sure sweetheart but we think that that Hollywood is actually in Los Angeles I said I'm in do you remember the moment that the technology that that that is specific to some of the parts of moviemaking really grabbed you
我只是用超8毫米摄像机之类的小设备拍过一些小电影 但我觉得自己居然真的能去把这变成现实 这种想法太陌生也太离奇了 我从来没真的想过这件事 但当我的父母问我是否想搬到洛杉矶 因为我父亲有机会调职到那里 我说那不就是好莱坞附近吗 然后我妈妈 我妈妈说 噢 我们其实不太确定 亲爱的 但我们觉得好莱坞实际上是在洛杉矶 我说 我去 你还记得吗 那种专门针对电影制作某些部分的真正吸引了你的技术
and you're like oh I'd love to incorporate that into some of the more traditional sort of filmmaking techniques and stuff what was it wasn't like that why you tell me I was just fascinated by all of it you know just grabbing a camera running around town shooting neon signs and cut that together in all kinds of crazy ways I mean all the stuff you do as a film student you know just trying to express yourself figure out what you have to say if anything sure you know but I remember 2001 a space Odyssey which I saw in 68 really kind of just tweaked my brain yeah about what was possible and then
然后你想 噢 我很乐意把这个融入到一些更传统的电影制作技术中去 究竟是什么 并不是那样的 怎么说呢 我只是对这一切都很着迷 你知道 拿着一台相机在城里跑来跑去 拍摄霓虹灯广告牌 并以各种疯狂的方式把它们剪辑在一起 我的意思是所有你在作为电影学生时做的事情 你知道 只是试图表达你自己 弄清楚你想说什么 如果有什么要说的话 当然 你知道 但我记得2001年的《2001太空漫游》 我是在1968年看的 真的让我脑洞大开
after that I got really interested in how things were done you know on the on big movies sure and you worked at you know when you were what did you do on escape from New York which I love that movie John Carpenter great movie yeah weren't you like the visual effects yeah photographer or something I was the co-supervisor of visual effects with another guy named Robert Skotak who is a pal of mine back then and we did it all really old-school stuff paintings on glass and things like that that's so cool Ernest Borgnine was in that yeah yeah do you know Jason has a real connection with Ernest Borgnine yeah do you have
关于什么是可能的 然后在那之后 我开始对大电影里是怎么制作各种效果的产生浓厚兴趣 你知道的 比如你曾在 你知道的 当你做过 《纽约大逃亡》里的什么工作 我很喜欢那部电影 约翰·卡朋特 伟大的电影 是啊 你不就是那个视觉效果 是啊 摄影师什么的 我是视觉效果的联合主管 另一个家伙叫罗伯特·斯科塔克 他是我当时的死党 我们做的全都是非常老派的东西 在玻璃上画画之类的 太酷了 欧内斯特·博格宁出演了那部电影 是啊 是啊 你知道杰森和欧内斯特·博格宁很有渊源吗 是啊 你
any you have any ability to prove the fact will's got a theory that Ernest Borgnine not there he gave an interview yeah Jason lives in Ernest Borgnine's old house wow and and will has convinced that not convinced he said in a couple interviews that somebody asked what was the key to his longevity and he claimed that it was a ritual of daily masturbation and I said Jason when you're in your house do you imagine Ernest you know in different parts of the house just kind of leaning over the banister up against the wall in the dining room whatever performing this act in in in an exercise standing up why
有什么 你有什么能力证明这个事实 威尔有一个理论 认为欧内斯特·博格宁不在那儿 他接受过采访 是啊 杰森住在欧内斯特·博格宁的老房子里 哇 并且 威尔坚信 不是坚信 他在几次采访中说过 有人问他长寿的秘诀是什么 他声称那是每天手淫的仪式 然后我说 杰森 当你在你的房子里时 你能想象欧内斯特 你知道的 在房子的不同角落 比如靠在楼梯扶手上 靠在餐厅的墙上 无论什么地方 在进行这种行为
because he's trying to stay older he's trying to live longer anyway James Cameron is here I think it's a good plan yeah the beauty of his plan is there's no downside you either live longer or you don't but at least you're enjoying it every day that's right they say live for every day right so there you go there you go thank you for that and it's also also it's a victim now did I see him wanking on the set now yeah I can't help you with that right you never came back you never came back to base camp and cut Ernest Borgnine snapping went off hey James just saying God I wish I was at home hey so I wanted to ask you
在一个锻炼动作中 站着 为什么 因为他想保持年轻 他想活得更久 无论如何 詹姆斯·卡梅隆在这里 我觉得这是一个好计划 是啊 他的计划的美妙之处在于没有任何缺点 你要么活得更久 要么活不长 但至少你每天都很享受 对吧 大家都说为每一天而活 对吧 所以就是这样 谢谢你带来的这个 而且它也是 另一个受害者 现在 我看到他在片场撸管了吗 是啊 我帮不了你这个 噢 你从来没有回过
sorry I wanted to ask you so was and please do correct me was the first film that you directed piranha to oh I was gonna say Terminator or piranha to right well the first bit it was the first big budget big studio movie you did so here's here's to clarify the first film I got hired to direct was piranha to I got fired about eight days into shooting wow because the producer just wanted to take over here that was his plan the whole time I was like I was like a sacrificial lamb and the first film that I actually fully directed was the Terminator so that's that's the only one I put on my resume that is that true
大本营去看欧内斯特·博格宁啪啪啪吗 嘿 詹姆斯 只是说说 天哪 我真希望我在家里 嘿 所以我想问你 抱歉 我想问你 那么 是不是 请务必纠正我 你导演的第一部电影是《食人鱼2》吗 我正想说《终结者》或是《食人鱼2》对吧 嘛 第一部它 是你拍的第一部大预算大制片厂电影 所以这里要澄清一下 我被雇去导演的第一部电影是《食人鱼2》 拍摄大约八天后我被解雇了 哇 因为制片人只想接手 那是他的整个计划 我就像 我就像一只替罪羊 而我真正完全导演的第一部电影是《终结者》 所以那是唯一一部我写进简历里的电影 这是真的吗
that you were living your car when you wrote it and all that not really I had an apartment in Tarzana but I used to go out to do pars on Ventura Boulevard late at night 3 a.m. and just right you just rock up in a booth and just right you know just to keep that kind of kind of dark film noir turn that into a Sephora now it's a Sephora yeah right oh baby yeah that's where did you get the idea like the idea is so incredible about sending somebody from the future in the back to stop somebody before they get before they you know the whole thing is so it's amazing where does that come from I kind of backed into it because it
你写它的时候住在车里 诸如此类 并不是真的 我在塔扎纳有一间公寓 但我经常在深夜3点去特扎纳的文图拉大道上写作 你就直接走到一个卡座里开始写 你知道 只是为了保持那种黑暗黑色电影的基调 现在那里变成丝芙兰了 现在是丝芙兰 是啊 对吧 噢 宝贝 是啊 你是从哪儿得到这个构意的 这个构意太不可思议了 关于从未来派遣某人在某人行动之前阻止他们 在他们 整个构意太神奇了 这是从哪儿来的 我其实是顺理成章想出来的 因为当时的想法是
was like all right what kind of film will they let me direct it's got to be something I could shoot on the streets of present day LA where I live it's got to be a little budget we can't do a lot of stuff maybe we can do it and they know you've just been fired off the fish movie so I had to factor that in too so it wasn't going to be a big budget so so then I thought all right so how can I get an extra but I wanted to also sort of make it up make my unique skill set valuable as an effects guy so I thought all right so what kind of effects science fiction story can I tell in the streets of LA well there's
好吧 他们会让我导演什么样的电影 必须是我能在现今我居住的洛杉矶街头拍摄的电影 预算必须很小 我们不能做太多事情 或许我们能做到 而且他们知道你刚刚被那部鱼的电影炒了鱿鱼 所以我也必须把这一点考虑进去 所以它不会是一个大预算 所以然后我想 好吧 那么我怎么能作为一个特效师让我的额外技能 也就是我独特的技能变得有价值呢 所以我想 好吧 那么我能在洛杉矶街头讲述一个什么样的特效科幻故事呢 好的 这里
only two ways to get something extraordinary here that's either from space or from somewhere else in time right so now all of a sudden boom okay it's a time travel story something comes for the future why okay and then you go into the grandfather paradox and and figure out you know so it kind of it just kind of dominoed from the kind of parameters of my life and what I needed to do yeah I mean because it none nothing of it looks low budget by the way I mean especially at the time and I heard and I haven't seen it lately but at the time it was like pretty incredible and and and I read somewhere
只有两种方法可以得到非同寻常的东西 那要么来自太空 要么来自时间中的其他地方 对吧 所以现在突然间 轰 好吧 这是一个时间旅行的故事 某个东西从未来而来 为什么 好吧 然后你陷入祖母悖论中 弄清楚 各种事情 所以它就像多米诺骨牌一样 从我生活的参数和我需要做的事情中延伸出来 是啊 我的意思是 顺便说一句 没有任何东西看起来像是低预算的 我的意思是 特别是在当时 我听说过 我最近没看过 但在当时 感觉相当不可思议 并且 我在哪儿读到过
that you like you kind of you didn't have permits and you kind of shot stuff illegally and like yeah what does law enforcement say to James Cameron before he's James Cameron yeah yeah we so we're out in the desert doing the final shot of the movie and you know we got a little wooden platform set up it was me my wife at the time actually we weren't married at the time Gail heard who produced it and her secretary and we had built this little camera platform to shoot the plate for the last shot and there's not nothing visible for 20 miles in any direction and this little glint on the horizon pulls up and it's a cop
你好像 你没有许可证 你有点非法拍摄 并且 执法部门在詹姆斯·卡梅隆成为詹姆斯·卡梅隆之前对他说过什么 是啊 是啊 我们当时在沙漠里拍电影的最后一个镜头 你知道的 我们搭了一个小木平台 那时是我 当时的妻子 实际上我们当时还没结婚 制作人盖尔·安妮·赫德 和她的秘书 我们搭建了这个小摄像机平台来拍摄最后一个镜头的底版 在任何方向二十英里内都看不到任何东西 地平线上出现了一道微弱的反光 停了下来 结果是个警察
I'm like you gotta be fucking kidding me and he he walks up to it says you have a permit to be doing this and I said no but I'm just a student at UCLA I think I was 29 at the time I said do we need a permit I didn't know that he goes well get that get that off this off the road we were on the road by like a foot and he drove away so that was it I just bullshitted my way out and so you cast and your cast is of course Arnold Schwarzenegger who at the time had been doing the Conan movies and stuff he wasn't like he wasn't this huge Conan international Conan whatever it is he wasn't this huge international
我想 你他妈的在逗我吧 他走过来问 你有许可证做这个吗 我说没有 但我只是加州大学洛杉矶分校的一个学生 我想我当时29岁 我说我们需要许可证吗 我不知道这个 他说 好了 把那个 从路上移开 我们当时离马路大概只有一英尺远 然后他就开车走了 所以就是这样 我用胡说八道糊弄过去了 所以你选角的 你的演员当然是阿诺·施瓦辛格 当时他一直在拍《野蛮人柯南》之类的电影 他并不是 那个时候他可不是那个巨大的柯南 国际柯南 无论什么 那个时候他并不是他后来成为的那个巨大的国际
superstar that he ended up becoming Terminator was really the sort of seminal role in his career at that point that was the thing that really shot him forward what was that like as a 20 young year 29 year old you know young filmmaker who's trying to make his mark with a guy who's coming from doing these films that weren't necessarily mainstream and big movies did you see was it like the perfect combination in a lot of ways for you guys yeah we clicked right away I mean Arnold Arnold is just all about discipline and all about you know perfection and trying as hard as you can mentally and physically and he saw
超级巨星 《终结者》真的是他职业生涯中具有开创性的角色 在那个时刻 那才是真正让他声名鹊起的作品 作为29岁的年轻电影制片人 试着跟一个来自这些并不一定是主流和大制作电影的演员一起打响名声 你的感受是什么样子的 你当时觉得这在很多方面对你们来说是不是完美的组合 是啊 我们一拍即合 我的意思是 阿诺 阿诺一切都关乎纪律 一切都关乎 你知道的 完美 并在精神上和身体上尽你所能去尝试 他从我身上看到
kind of kindred spirit in me because you know we were trying to move mountains to make this movie he loved the film I mean they had the axe all sharpened up and poised to chop me off on day two if I if I tripped up they had another director waiting in the wings and and Arnold really kind of had my back on that movie that's great that's amazing wow and we will be right back people often ask me they say will they say what sets GMC trucks apart and I tell them it's not just the announcer in their commercials okay even though that guy is absolutely tremendous and he happens to be professional grade you know what it
了一种志同道合的精神 因为你知道 我们当时为了拍这部电影在移山倒海 他很喜欢这部电影 我的意思是 他们已经磨快了斧头 准备在第二天如果我搞砸了就把我炒了 他们有另一个导演在侧翼候场 而阿诺在那部电影里确实挺我 太棒了 太棒了 哇 我们马上回来 人们经常问我 他们会说 威尔 他们说是什么让GMC卡车与众不同 我告诉他们 这不仅仅是因为他们广告里的配音员 好吧 尽管那个家伙绝对非常棒 而且他恰如其分地达到了专业级别 你知道那是什么
is it's GMC's commitment to building premium and capable trucks that set them apart case in point the first-ever all-electric GMC Sierra EV Denali Edition 1 it's powered by Altium battery technology and it delivers incredible agility power and capability and for next-level versatility there is a new multi-pro mid-gate that can fold down for astounding bed space and flexibility that's what makes the GMC Sierra EV Denali Edition 1 the Denali of EVs and that is what sets GMC apart it's kind of a long answer but it happens to be true so that obviously all of that and also their sweet announcer
是GMC致力于打造高端且性能卓越的卡车 这才是他们与众不同的地方 举个例子 有史以来第一款全电动GMC悍马Sierra EV Denali第一版 它由奥特能电池技术驱动 带来了令人难以置信的灵活性 动力和性能 为了实现更高水平的多功能性 车上配备了一个全新的MultiPro中门 可以向下折叠 以获得惊人的货箱空间和灵活性 这就是为什么GMC Sierra EV Denali第一版成为了电动车中的Denali 这就是GMC与众不同的地方 这是一个有点长的回答 但它恰好是事实
just voiced like a like a nightingale who ain't like a pound of gravel GMC Sierra EV Denali Edition 1 available in early 2024 by reservation only Sierra EV Denali available spring 2024 SmartList is sponsored by BetterHelp so I talk about therapy a lot I know you guys are used to that and I hopefully you're taking advantage of BetterHelp because it really really helps but like for example I have a lot of stress as you know as I openly share with you guys and you know part like this sounds so stupid but on my right pinky I have tendonitis and as you know I play the
所以显然所有这些 还有他们甜美的配音员 声音听起来就像一只夜莺 却又像吞了一磅砂砾 GMC Sierra EV Denali第一版 2024年初上市 仅限预订 Sierra EV Denali 2024年春季上市 SmartList由BetterHelp赞助 所以我经常谈论心理治疗 我知道你们对此已经习惯了 希望你们能充分利用BetterHelp 因为它真的真的很有帮助 但比如 我有很多压力 如你们所知 正如我向你们坦诚分享的那样 你知道 部分 听起来很蠢 但在我的右手小指上 我有肌腱炎
piano and it's freaking me out I'm stressed out there's a lot of pressure and stress coming up with the show I'm doing a Broadway and so I was the first thing I talked to last time in therapy I was like how do I cope with this you know calm down first you got to take a step-by-step and she helped me walk through especially when you get that stressed out you can't take on the whole world all at once and all your problems all at once it's got to be step-by-step day-by-day inch-by-inch so you can feel like you can control it and attack it with the right plan that works for you and that's just stuff I learned through
如你们所知 我弹钢琴 这把我吓坏了 我压力很大 即将到来的节目给我带来了很大的压力和紧张 我正在演百老汇 所以这是我上次在心理治疗中谈论的第一件事 我说我该如何应对这个呢 你知道 先冷静下来 你必须一步一步来 她帮我梳理 尤其是当你感到压力那么大时 你不可能一下子承担起全世界和你的所有问题 你必须一步一步来 日复一日 一寸一寸 这样你才能觉得你可以掌控它 并用适合你的正确计划去攻克它 而这些正是我通过
therapy if I don't work on this on my own I'd be lost but but because me and my therapist are like more of a team it really really helps and I know I I know it's somebody that can count on who's gonna listen to me and give me the right advice just not something I want to hear right as the world's largest therapy service better help has matched 3 million people with professionally licensed and vetted therapists available 100% online plus it's affordable just fill out a brief questionnaire to match with a therapist if things aren't clicking you can easily switch to a new therapist anytime it couldn't be simpler no
心理治疗学到的东西 如果我自己不处理这个 我就迷失了 但因为我和我的治疗师更像是一个团队 它真的真的很有帮助 而且我知道 我知道这是一个我可以依赖的人 他会倾听我的意见并给我正确的建议 而不仅仅是我想听的话 作为全球最大的心理治疗服务机构 BetterHelp已经将300万人和拥有专业执照且经过审核的治疗师匹配在一起 100%在线提供 此外价格实惠 只需填写一份简短的问卷即可与治疗师匹配 如果感觉不对盘 你可以随时轻松更换新治疗师
waiting rooms no traffic no endless searching for the right therapist learn more and save 10% off your first month at betterhelp.com slash smart list that's better help HELP.com slash smart list we're brought to you in part by athletic greens so listen I started taking AG1 because of a lot of reasons because of the convenience I don't have like the row of bottles and you know things on my kitchen counter like this pill that supplement that vitamin it's all in one great tasting thing called AG1 but also it's great for gut health because I don't know if you know this but some a
再简单不过了 没有候诊室 没有交通 没有无休止地寻找合适的治疗师 在betterhelp.com/smartlist了解更多信息并节省首月10%的费用 也就是betterhelp H-E-L-P.com/smartlist 我们部分节目由Athletic Greens赞助 所以听着 我开始服用AG1有很多原因 因为它的便利性 我不需要像别人那样在厨房台面上摆一排瓶子和各种东西 比如这个药丸 那个补剂 那个维生素 它全都在一个味道极佳的叫做AG1的东西里 而且它对肠道健康也很好
lot of scientists call your gut your second brain so if your gut is in good shape that means your brain is in good shape and I've felt the difference drinking AG1 I'm in a better mood it just lifts your spirit like it takes care of all that stuff look we all can work on disciplining ourselves but one thing I'm working on and discipline myself is getting up every morning and taking this because it's right there it's so easy and it's fast and it's so good for you this blend of ingredients supports your gut health your nervous system your immune system your energy recovery focus and aging sustainable routines are key AG1
因为我不知道你知不知道这一点 某些 许多科学家将你的肠道称为你的第二大脑 所以如果你的肠道状态良好 这意味着你的大脑状态良好 而且我感觉到了喝AG1的区别 我的情绪更好了 它确实能提振你的精神 就像它能照顾好所有这些事情 看 我们都可以努力克制自己 但我正在努力克制自己的一件事是每天早上起床服用这个 因为它就在那儿 太简单了 而且很快 对你太有好处了 这种成分混合物支持你的肠道健康 你的神经系统 你的免疫系统 你的能量 恢复 专注力和抗衰老 可持续的日常习惯是关键 AG1
is my daily micro habit that makes it easy to absorb key nutrients lead a healthy lifestyle and feel my best no matter what the day holds one scoop one minute once a day every day right now it's time to reclaim your health and arm your immune system with convenient daily nutrition it's just one scoop in a cup of water every day that's it no need for a million different pills and supplements to look out for your health athletic greens is going to give you a free one-year supply of immune-supporting vitamin D and five free travel packs with your first purchase all you have to do is visit athletic greens comm slash
是我每天的微习惯 让我能够轻松吸收关键营养 保持健康的生活方式 无论这一天如何都能展现最佳状态 一勺 一分钟 每天一次 每天如此 现在是时候重塑你的健康 并用便捷的日常营养来武装你的免疫系统了 每天只需在一杯水中加一勺 就这样 不需要成百万上万种不同的药丸和补充剂来照顾你的健康 Athletic Greens将为你的首次购买免费提供一年份支持免疫的维生素D以及五包免费旅行装 你所需要做的就是访问athletic greens.com/smartlist 再说一遍 是athletic greens.com/smartlist 来掌控你的健康 并选择终极的日常营养保障 现在回到节目中
smart list again that's athletic greens comm slash smart list to take ownership over your health and pick up the ultimate daily nutritional insurance and now back to the show how far do you think we are from completely replacing actors with computer-generated people because they're kind of doing that or or well they are doing that on online right with deep fakes and stuff like that are that are really really convincing is that not that you know I'm looking to get actors out of movies being one but but I'll bet you that there are moments like if you need to fill in crowds and stuff like that there's already that you know
你觉得我们距离用电脑生成的虚拟人物完全取代演员还有多远 因为他们某种程度上正在那样做 或者 或者是的 他们在网上正在那样做 比如用深度伪造技术以及诸如此类非常非常逼真的技术 这并不是说 你知道 我想让演员失业 虽然我就是个演员 但我敢打赌 比如如果你需要填补群众演员之类的角色 已经有那种 你知道的 贴图了 是啊 是啊 但就像实际上 把某人在前景中放在一个标记上念台词 你在某种程度上正在这样做 当你
the tiles yeah yeah but like actually actually putting somebody in the foreground on a mark saying lines you know you're doing that to a certain extent when you're no it's not what we do like with the Avatar films it's a it's a very actor-centric actor-driven process yeah we're not trying to replace the actor we're trying to to perfect what they did in a character that doesn't resemble them as much physically right so in a sense it's more like makeup it's a hundred percent actor-driven and we always honor the performance and the nuance of that performance and you'll you'll see it in the new film that's my
不 这跟我们所做的不一样 比如对于《阿凡达》电影 这是一个非常以演员为中心 演员驱动的过程 是的 我们不是在试图取代演员 我们是在完善他们在那些外表上不那么像他们的角色中所做的事情 对吧 所以从某种程度上来说 它更像是化妆 它是100%由演员驱动的 并且我们总是尊重表演以及那个表演的细微差别 你会在新电影中看到这一点的 这就是我的推销 我说完了 但关键是 如果我在拍第一部电影时 我会说绝对不会 今天 了解了人工智能以及人工通用智能的发展和正在进行的全部工作之后 我会说
pitch I'm done but the but the kicker is I would have said never when I made the first film today with what I know about AI and and the developments in artificial general intelligence and all the work that's being done I would say if you converge the toolset that we have created for Avatar and focused it literally put money into that and focused it in terms of getting it closer to a real-time process and you added AI to that you could fake anything you just can't do it yet you can't do it in real time you can do it with a one month or five months lag right now perfectly which is kind of what we do we had 3200
如果你将我们为《阿凡达》创造的工具集融合起来 并且专注于此 真正投入资金将其更贴近实时处理进程 并且你在其中加入人工智能 你可以伪造任何东西 只是你现在还做不到 你无法实时做到这一点 你现在可以用一个月或五个月的延迟来完美地做到这一点 这差不多也就是我们所做的 我们在《阿凡达2》中有3200个镜头证明了这一点 但你认为追求这一点 沿着这个方向发展有任何价值吗 我认为这更多地关乎 我们是否想要拥有我们可以穿戴或者投影到元宇宙类型环境或游戏环境中的逼真虚拟人物 对吧 我认为这与我们如何创造娱乐没有任何关系
shots in in Avatar 2 that prove that but do you think there's any do you think there's any value in pursuing that in going down that direction I think that it has more to do with do we want to have photo real avatars that we can we can wear or project within into a metaverse type environment or a gaming environment right I don't think it has any anything to do with how we would create our entertainment it's still just so much easier and by the way more fun to just work with actors yeah what about for like a little reshoot though you know like I say your actors gone off and cut their hair and you got to do a
它仍然要简单得多 顺便说一句 直接与演员合作也更有趣 是啊 不过对于一些小型的补拍呢 你知道的 比如说你的演员剪了头发 你必须做一个 小小的 哎 对吧 是啊 但你仍然是用 你的确还是用演员来做 所以比如在我们的故事里有一个人类小孩 如果我需要为《阿凡达3》补拍他的镜头 他在角色上已经长大了 我的迈尔斯 你知道的 他长高了一英尺半 他变声了两个八度 你知道的 我们可以重新调整他的声音 但我们无法改变他身体和脸部的衰老 所以如果我需要那个补拍镜头 我会让他来 我们进行捕捉 我们有他的模型 然后我们基本上只是把他作为一个人放进电影里
little a little yeah right yeah but you still do it with the you'd still do it with the actor see so like we got a this human kid and our story if I need a pickup with him for Avatar 3 he's already aged out of the part my miles you know he's he's a foot and a half taller he's two octaves down you know we can repitch his voice but we can't change his body and face aging so if I need that pickup I'll have him come in we'll capture it we have his model and we'll basically just put him in the movie as a human huh all right so I have like a little bit of a long so hang in there this is what I love about you James
呼 好吧 所以我有一个稍微有点长的 坚持住 这就是我喜欢你的地方 詹姆斯·卡梅隆 吉姆 现在 我们叫你吉姆可以吧 轻松点 是啊 所以我喜欢你的一点是 你是一个彻头彻尾的“能搞定它”的人 对吧 所以非常快的一个超级快的故事 当我 当我的制作公司制作了一部名为《格林》的节目时 我记得我推销《格林》推销了大约七年 一次又一次 我们向人们推销 他们会 不太理解 我们把它束之高阁 然后再次推销它 我当时在某家电视台的某次会议上 这位高级别的高管说 噢
Cameron Jim now now we can call you Jim right easy yeah so what I love about you is you're a total like a figure it out or right so really quick super fast story when I was my production company we made a show called grim and I remember pitching grim for like seven years over and over we'd pitch it people wouldn't like kind of not get it we'd put it on a shelf we'd pitch it again and I was in this one meeting at this one network and this high-level executive was like gosh because there's a lot special effects in it they would say they said to me gosh that seems so hard to do that seems really really hard to do every week in
因为里面有很多特效 他们会说 他们对我说 噢 这看起来太难做了 每一集 每一季看起来都真的真的很难做 我讽刺地回答说 那么我们就别做了 意思是每件事都很难 对吧 所以 对你来说 这就是让我对你感到震惊的地方 你那种能力的来源是什么 因为一部接一部又一部电影 就像 那种能力的来源是什么 让你对自己的想法如此深信不疑 以至于你似乎愿意牺牲几乎一切来将其实现 比如说 我记得几十年前读到过关于制片厂为《泰坦尼克号》开了一张又一张支票的事 因为不知何故你让坚信这一切都会成功 显然它确实成功了
episode episode to which I sarcastically replied well then let's just not do it like meaning everything is hard right so so for you which I'm this is what blows my mind about you where did the ability come from to because movie after movie after movie is like where did the ability come from to trust your ideas so deeply that you're seemingly willing to sacrifice almost everything to see it through like for example I remember reading decades ago about the studio writing check after check for Titanic because somehow you convinced them that all this is gonna work and obviously it did but you succeed in this philosophy
而你在这种理念上一次又一次地取得成功 这种底气是从哪里来的 让你觉得“相信我 我能搞定” 你知道的 嘛 我觉得有这样一回事 当你在脑海中看到它时 就像你在看电影一样 所以你差不多就知道这部电影好还是不好 对吧 我的意思是 带有某种准确度 其次 一旦你走上了这条路 并且你发现它是多么困难 你知道的 你真的无法退出 我无法退出 制片厂也无法退出 所以我们只能硬着头皮把它演完 然后我觉得会发生这样一件事 那么你的卓越标准最好提高一些 因为你不能搞砸
over and over again where do the balls come from to just be like trust me I got this you know well I think there's a thing of when you see it in your head it's kind of like you're watching the movie so you kind of know then that the movies good or not good right I mean within with some degree of accuracy and secondly once you're down the path and you find out how hard it is you know you can't really pull out I can't pull out studio can't pull out so we just got to play it through and then I think there's something that happens that all right well your standards of excellence better go up then because you can't screw this
这个 是啊 我觉得这是其中的一部分 你知道的 但看 任何种类的艺术家 演员 具象艺术家 无论什么 都必须对自己想说的话有信心 首先才能称自己为艺术家 如果他们得到了积极的反馈 是啊 凭借他们的前几部问世的作品 那么这种信心就会提升 对吧 是啊 你学会了相信自己的直觉 你同样对通过技术可能实现的东西有着如此全面和深刻的理解 换句话说 你知道你可以向制片厂老板推销某些东西 而对方可能会说 听起来很贵 不不 我们可以用电脑做到这一点 诸如此类
up yeah I think that's part of it you know but look every every artist of any kind actor a figurative artist whatever has to have the confidence in what they have to say to call themselves an artist in the first place and if they get positive feedback yeah with their first few works that are out there then that confidence goes goes up right yeah you learn to trust your instincts you also have such a such a full understanding of what is possible through technology as well in other words you know you can pitch something in a studio head might say well that sounds really expensive no no we can do that with computers blah
对，我想这也是其中的一部分，你知道的，但是看吧，任何类型的艺术家——演员、具象艺术家或其他什么——首先都必须对他们要表达的东西有信心，才敢自称为艺术家，如果他们最初的几件作品得到了积极的反馈，那么这种信心就会增强，对吧？是的，你学会了相信自己的直觉，同时你也对技术所能实现的一切有了非常充分的理解，换句话说，你知道你可以提出一个构想，而电影公司老板可能会说“听起来真的很贵”，而你可以回答“不不，我们可以用电脑来实现这一点，等等”。
blah blah how are you able to stay current with what is possible and cost effective based on how easy it is for that technology to be accessed etc. are you the one that's that's actually driving what is now possible technologically as opposed to making sure you read the right article to make sure you stay up to date on what's possible yeah it's both I mean when we evaluate a project going into it we'll look at what the state of the art is and we'll identify the areas where we have to you know up the game and that's where we'll put our R&D money and we'll look at the we'll look at our schedule and say
46|||blah blah how are you able to stay current with what is possible and cost effective based on how easy it is for that technology to be accessed etc. are you the one that's that's actually driving what is now possible technologically as opposed to making sure you read the right article to make sure you stay up to date on what's possible yeah it's both I mean when we evaluate a project going into it we'll look at what the state of the art is and we'll identify the areas where we have to you know up the game and that's where we'll put our R&D money and we'll look at the we'll look at our schedule and say
all right we got two years to come up with water simulations you know computational fluid dynamics sims for ocean water we've got X amount of time and it just becomes a budget line item so do you then have do you have people who are writing code for that who work for you yeah yeah so and you're and you're directing them saying okay guys this is what we want to do we want to do the water thing or whatever it is and they go great and they start to model it out and they start writing code for it and which really yeah and then the studio and then the students are sorry Sean the studio then is financing the
the R&D the making of that for that one film are they then not to get in the weeds of all this stuff I apologize but are they then in line to reap the profits of that technology going forward for other projects at other studios kind of yes kind of no it works like this if we develop something for avatar and usually that's in the form of an asset like a creature or a setting or something like that that exists digitally it sits in a server they can reap the benefit of not having to recreate that every time so the movies have a kind of economy of scale over the over the greater arc you know which is
why a scene doc yeah exactly it's like a digital scene doc it's exactly that and and your creatures and and so on you know you can just call that stuff back up so that that's part of the argument for doing you know three or four films kind of back-to-back for the technology that you would use let's say for to make water better today than it was five years ago let's say Studio X funded that movie during which you developed the code that made water better now in five years or a year later you know Universal does something that has sure they need to use it now does Studio X get reimbursed for that for that having
developed that code not really no they just kind of they they spend the money to make that movie the thing is we're leaving out an entity which is the visual effects company right so we work very closely with what a visual effects right down down here in New Zealand where I'm right now they will develop they'll develop that code now they'll use some of the money from what we pay them they'll use some of their own internal resources to do it and then we can go back to them anytime we want and and take advantage of it and it's proprietary for them yeah exactly yeah yeah I'll explain it to Jason later let
me ask you about me out a lot today well thank you well we could have just done it in a second so Jim let me ask you this can you can you did you play well today I did not think you did I had a grumpy day so so Jim did you I hate that you know that Jim can you tell me what happened when you got into all this stuff with actual underwater stuff when you were in submarines and doing all that kind of stuff I mean I had like a nine-hour list of questions about all that yeah now I love that stuff that's I mean I sort of reached a point when I made Titanic where I was making the movie because I wanted to dive to the
wreck I had done a lot of I had done thousands of hours underwater by then on scuba right but I hadn't done anything with submersibles I'd made a movie about subs and about ROVs called the abyss but and we built all the stuff for the movie but we never took it in the ocean so I wanted to go do something for real with with deep diving and then so Titanic was a way of kind of serving both of my greatest interest someone project and worked out great made a bunch of money and then I spent eight years doing expeditions building robots building underwater cameras building submersibles and just kind of turned my back on the
whole filmmaking thing for about eight years that's amazing and then you come back to making the films and doing this like super ambitious stuff with the avatars but but is there part of you that's like I do you prefer one to the other do you wish you were just doing more exploration or yeah sometimes the filmmaking just kind of subsidized that in a way yeah kind of I mean it has so far it's worked out that way you know avatar made a bunch of money so then I built a sub to go to the you know the deepest places on the planet and worked on that for several years after after avatar made those dives in in 2012 so
yeah for me it's a full life it doesn't really make sense to a lot of people looking at it from the outside because in the entertainment business we always put that first like it's the most important thing in the world and everything is all very self-referential within that reality bubble but I was on the NASA advisory council I've been in lots of environments where they don't even think about movies we don't even exist for them maybe on a ship maybe on a ship when you're out doing something really important somebody will throw in you know a VH a VHS you know of some comedy that's all that's not the
Senate well luckily it's not for me either because I've only made really bad movies and TV shows and everything's been canceled but it's okay I'm not successful in that way but I'm good at a dinner party gym keep that in mind it's so fascinating that it just occurred to me that you are incredible at creating fake life and you are incredible at exploring the real raw you know building blocks of real life you know checking out like you know the depths of the earth yeah where the the the the the boring stuff I guess in comparison the stuff in the middle the stuff where we the rest of us live right domestic sort
of life how did you are you comfortable with the amount of time you spend in that lane as well you are well I got five kids yeah and that that's wow that's its own whole epic journey right you guys have kids right yeah yeah yeah I've got three Jason's got two yeah yeah I got a dog yeah well it's similar yeah they scream and shit everywhere yeah except you never have to come down and bail out your dog yeah but that's yeah that's it's such an interesting you're you're so incredible both of those polls and we just never hear about how awesome you are right there in the middle but I'll bet you but that's where we live
that's where we really live right so the new then with the new avatar sequels I thought like the way I brought that around yeah I wanted to talk about the shit that I'd been living for years as a father as a husband and all that sort of thing and the dysfunction in families the the power and the strength that comes from being in a family and what that all means and then put that back into you know what I do as a director in the same way I wanted to bring the underwater stuff into the directing which I did on prior films I wanted to do family so that's the so these avatar films are about family told from the
parents perspective and from the kids perspective yeah by the way you can talk about avatar all you want I'm one of my favorite I'm obsessed I can't believe I'm talking to you all right so you've been to the deepest part of the ocean first of all where did the love of the ocean come from why are you why are you obsessed with it and is it true that you went down you've been down deeper than any other human is that true I've been down as deep as a couple of other humans like seven miles yeah it's almost seven just one more foot yeah well the problem is that when you get that deep it's actually hard to know how deep you
really are with great accuracy like to within a foot you can't do it within a foot you can do it within kind of 30 40 feet something like that yeah and it was seven miles you say it's almost seven miles 35,000 35,000 800 I know how in the world did you how in the world does something exist that can survive the pressure of that we built it yeah built it we built it yeah you went so deep and then you got to get a question from somebody who's so shallow Jim Jim can you can you there's a clip there's a clip you do a lot of so you've made a living doing a lot of these great things and of course you've done with no
because the deep sea and you do all that and a lot of I guess I hate to use the term science fiction because it feels almost too broad or it feels good but is that what interests you if you're gonna watch something if you're on a long plane ride down to New Zealand for instance I imagine you work all the time but if you were to take the moment to watch other films and watch or those things you do you watch science fiction or do you watch yeah dramas or do you watch comedy everything everything everything yeah I probably lean more toward drama science fiction historical fiction that sort of thing comedy more
when I'm with the family sure cuz I don't do it you know but there's always that aspect when you watch a movie and you get really enthusiastic about it you know you're learning something that you can apply back to your own art I'm gonna pitch you a really great comedy series about a guy who's got the bends but we'll get into it later where do you land on that be sure to be very short it's very short it's very sad actually they got a very sad where do you land on documentary because I'll bet you've got a lot of footage of just your expeditions that yeah that you've played with well you do you have one that was
they were all funded by the doc like so the documentaries help pay for the expeditions right so I think I've done right now as as producer and or director somewhere like 11 or 12 documentaries yeah and you know one of the best ones called deep sea challenge where that's the one where you built your own submarine yeah I love deep sea challenge and then there was a ghost to the abyss which was about Titanic but but you know 3d documentary about the wreck and so on stuff like that do you enjoy sort of again the polarity of you know sitting in an editing room and seeing what you got and shaping something from that yeah
it's more the typical documentary experience and and then in in avatar you've got to not only have a script but you're you're creating a lot of things digitally so the amount of planning where there is right almost zero surprise about creating in the editing room I would imagine in comparison to the process of documentary filmmaking again like where is that middle lane do you have any interest in that you know well I love I love editing yeah and I think I learned more editing documentaries than I did from editing features but I think what I brought back into editing let's say on avatar 2 is it's an exploration
just because you got all this footage doesn't mean you're a slave to it you know and the story will reassert itself in the editing process it's almost like a new draft of the script if you will yeah is it ever tempting as I hear they do an animation to completely recreate a scene an act as opposed to going back rewriting reshooting you can almost take an animated approach with it I'm asking now not what we're doing I mean Pixar could do that all day long but once again it's an actor-centric process so I'd literally have to rewrite the scene get the actors back together you know capture it again gotcha now I
could take a line from another scene and I could recreate the setting that I need and drop that line drop that actors performance if it worked you know you'd have to do it and we've done that a couple of times but the fun with the CG is I could take a scene that was shot supposedly as a as a day scene and make it night and make it rain just like in like that okay guys we're making that scene night I love to skip night Sean he could Sean he could Sean he could shoot a scene with you and he could probably paint out the Skittles so they wouldn't be in your yeah you're right next to you can also make it rain Skittles which
would make it rain you know it's interesting you use all this technology not only you use the technology you're an innovator when it comes to technology and it's funny that Terminator and the Terminator films are about a sort of a cautionary tale of technology gone awry if you will are you afraid of the machines oh absolutely well I'm not afraid but but I'm certainly pretty pretty concerned about the potential for misuse of AI yeah I think AI can be great I also think it could you know it could literally be the end of the world I mean you talk to all of the AI scientists and I know a bunch of them
and they every time I put my hand up at one of their you know their seminars or something they just start laughing oh that's that's guy that guy yeah sure we really want to hear from you and you know the point is that no technology has ever not been weaponized yeah yeah and do we really want to be fighting something smarter than us that isn't us on our own world I don't think so I mean look at AI could have taken over the world and already be manipulating it and we just don't know because it would have control over all the all the media and everything and what better explanation for how absurd everything is right now
nothing makes a damn bit of sense to me I don't know about you guys that's exactly right well yeah I mean you're you're there but as you know here we're living in a place that where it just seems very upside down and people are believing seemingly everything and it's a great point which is potentially if the AI is smarter than us and has the potential to be smarter than us why would it let us know that it was beating us because that would be that would be foolish of it to do that that's right be so easy to cover up it would be so easy to cover up but do you feel a responsibility have you ever felt or do
you feel increasingly a responsibility to to have more of a message I was gonna say I don't know in your films do you try to yeah yeah well I mean that the Avatar films are about the environment I'm not dealing with AI you know if I were to do another Terminator film and maybe try to try to launch that franchise again which is in discussion but nothing's been decided I would make it much more about about the AI side of it then then kind of bad robots gone gone crazy please I would watch that because the AI thing not not to put the audience to sleep because I've done that before talking about this subject
but it just for clarification for me because you you know this answer I'll bet you AI is it's about a computing speed right it's an ability to absorb a bunch of information process it and spit it back out I think it has more to do with with understanding human consciousness so that we collectively human technologists can create an intelligence that functions the way we do meaning they call it generally they call it aid AGI artificial general intelligence that it's not just designed to play chess and beat your asset chess it's designed to solve all kinds of problems so it it needs more of a
consciousness the way we view and react to the world and that's made possible just because it's able to absorb so much information fast amounts of data yes you're right so so there's AI and there's AGI so AI learns AI is more simple more more directed functions and what they do is they just show a whole bunch of training data into it all the books in the world yeah kind of or all the or you know all the YouTube all the all the Twitter you know everything and they just they just force-feed it vast amounts of what they call training data right and from that training data they pose it a problem and says all right
try a million different things and see what works better than what and then try another million things and it basically is just throwing processing time at the problem well and then there's so much computing power you know and in all our devices I'm Sean probably doesn't want me to tell this but his his Roomba has been listening to a minute just ordered Chinese food last night it's learning yeah well you know who's gonna be vacuuming the room in about five years ain't gonna be Roomba no it ain't gonna be Roomba it's gonna be us for the cam for the machines yeah we'll be right back smart list is supported by
FedEx this holiday season be ready for what's next with picture proof of delivery from FedEx picture proof of delivery provides photo confirmation of your delivered package so both consumers and businesses can have greater peace of mind FedEx Express and FedEx Ground are the first nationwide carriers to provide picture proof of delivery without requiring an account or login for residential deliveries it's available for free on the FedEx website and app best part is you don't have to enroll in any program you can simply track shipments online or subscribe to notifications so like for me I love this
because when I send an email to somebody I want to know they got it so I have a couple I have a few friends in my life them like look if I email you you don't have to email back like a long thing just go got it you know or just like received and so I do that and like with some people in business too and I love that because you want to know it's like when you get a gift for somebody you're not looking for a thank you you just want to know they got it right that's why I love picture proof of delivery thank you FedEx my god so ship with FedEx and be ready for this holiday season with picture proof of delivery FedEx be ready
for what's next smartlist is supported by audible you don't ride an elevator for the music I hope not or pick an airline for the movies I hope not so when it comes to audio entertainment doesn't it make sense to choose audible I mean it's in the title and the word of their company it's the home for stories told by the biggest stars like Ethan Hawke Kerry Washington and Kevin Hart it's home to epic adventures chilling mysteries and can't miss comedies audible is the home of storytelling let your imagination soar with audiobooks podcasts and originals so for me I know shocker sci-fi I actually listen to a
brief history of time actually read the book a long time ago and then I just listen to it again talk about transporting yourself to another world this transported me to another universe get it because it talks about the universe audible is the home of storytelling with all your audio entertainment in one app find the best of what you love or something new to discover audible has an incredible selection of audiobooks across every genre from bestsellers and new releases to celebrity memoirs mysteries and thrillers motivation wellness business so much more as an audible member you can
choose one title a month to keep from their entire catalog including the latest bestsellers and new releases members also get full access to a growing selection of included audiobooks audio originals and podcasts you can download or stream their included titles all you want let audible help you discover new ways to laugh be inspired or be entertained new members can try for free for 30 days visit audible.com slash smartless or text smartless to 500 500 that's audible.com slash smartless or text smartless to 500 500 to try audible free for 30 days audible.com slash smartless
smartless listeners this episode is brought to you by Zell when anyone sends money or if you need to get paid back always ask for Zell with Zell the money goes straight into your bank account you don't have to download another app because it's probably already in your banking app it's in over 1600 different banking apps and it works even if the sender banks somewhere different than you in the United States Jason will and I use Zell all the time to pay each other back so we're gonna do like these business Christmas corporate gifts thing and we haven't decided who is going to go buy them and then but whoever does is
gonna pay the other people back using Zell we haven't decided who's gonna go out and buy them but it doesn't matter because we have the confidence of using Zell to get the other person paid back what they deserve so the bad news is we don't know what we're doing for gifts but the good news is when we do we got Zell look for Zell and you're banking app today all right back to the show no wait I'm but Jim to give it to that point Jason's point that you were talking about did you ever see the movie Ex Machina yeah it's great it's it deals with that issue yeah it's yeah it's that same issue
about creating a robot or an AI that actually figures out how to mimic everything that is human so that the human is fooled well what they say to you know people that are on the spectrum to say fake it till you make it you know it's like it's like just figure just watch behavior and then learn from it and then you'll fit in better you know and that's just what they'll do that's what AGI will do I heard somebody told me a couple years ago that and maybe you probably heard that you've been at a lot of these these conferences and symposiums and whatever gatherings yeah that that this is at least two years
ago this person said to me that somebody at alphabet or Google or whatever had said to them that they were not concerned but they said it is the the algorithm is already doing things on itself that they don't understand how it knows how to do that's right and that's the big problem with using AI to solve any problem is you may get a good result but it can't tell you what it did right because because it's just randomly problem solving hundreds of millions of times and then just course correcting within that and it doesn't necessarily know why it's better to do it this way versus that way it just knows
that it is and so it'll just keep doing that and iterating so it can't tell you I can't tell you how it's solving the problem because it doesn't know that's crazy it's gonna start making movies Jim you've taught it to make movies now it's gonna start making movies and it's not gonna know why what me man what about crypto I want to know because do you believe in crypto no no good for you with all of this intelligent stuff it do you do anything that's real dumb ass what's what's the stupidest thing that you do I could I could tell you some really stupid things but it'll get back to my kids and then see that what
about like a dumb hobby like I do you love playing marbles bowling bowling bowling yeah you and Mookie bets yeah Gene Simmons of kiss taught me to bowl at his birthday party about 30 years ago and I actually enjoyed it it's like who knew bowling was what have you bowled a perfect game yet no have you gotten close I have gotten real drunk bet everybody like a lot of money that I would throw a strike and thrown it and then walk down of course that was a mic drop because I knew I could never do it again do you are you a sports guy do you follow any sports at all no not interested I have limited Ram and I need to use it for
what I need to use it for do you do you think it's a waste of time I watch a lot of sports am I wasting my time if you haven't fun you're not wasting your time okay now how do you like it what are you doing down there in New Zealand you still working on the on the movie we're just finishing up we're we're mixing the last couple reels you know as we speak finishing up we started out with thirty two hundred and fifty shots I'm down to twelve so yeah exactly how do you how do you zoom out and have like perspective and on something like that I'll get back to you on that when is the first one coming out okay so so avatar the way
of water is coming out in December and then two years later avatar three you know we haven't officially picked the title yet yeah comes which you've already shot we've shot it and we're post on it I've seen a cut of the film but we still have to finish all the effects it's that three thousand shot thing starts again is that is that what's driving the two year gap between it or was that intentional to have it be two years yeah it's just the finish work it takes us about two years to finish a movie that's otherwise all shot and edited yeah are you are you are so are you kind of guy it strikes me that you
might be that you're up at sort of 5 a.m. looking at stuff you're working all day you sleep a few hours and then you're back you wake up because you're bothered by unfinished business sometimes I'll wake up with the answer to a problem I don't usually wake up because I'm bothered by it but every once in a while there's a eureka moment right yeah but I know I get up at 5 every day I work out a noodle around for a while you know family stuff and then I you know go to work at 8 and work 12 hours where do you do your best thinking are you a walker are you are you stare at a wall do you what where do you know like on
planes some people really see clearly at a wall yeah planes are good walks are good you know dreams are good yeah dreams are good yeah I do a lot of work in in dreams and it's not any kind of trained kind of lucid dreaming just it's just sometimes solutions just work themselves out really you'd be a great person to take us into that that that unknown place you know what what dream where they come from where I think it's amazing yeah why don't we do that next please do that I was trying to answer a question another filmmaker had asked me in one of these kind of staged interview things in a magazine like you know about the
screenwriting process and I said we're everybody is screenwriting every night yeah we've got an engine in our head that tells a story in the form of a dream every single night you know it's like I think when we're screenwriting we're just formalizing that process or giving that engine you know more more power or more dominance over our consciousness yeah have you have you have you have you ever actually legitimately had a dream and you've written it down and it's become the nucleus of like an idea of a natural film really absolutely a terminator yeah terminator I had an image in a dream of this metal skeleton
coming out of the fire like boom wrote that down avatar you know I saw the luminous forest in a in a dream with the little spinning lizards and all that stuff drew it I didn't write it down I drew it I painted it and I was thinking I was 19 when yeah yeah really yeah and so that way so avatar was something that was always there kind of in the back of your back of your mind it was this thing that you this for years yeah this thing for years he wanted to yeah for for how you know I mean at this point that was half a century ago but it wasn't in the form of avatar wasn't in the form of that story it was just random imagery you
know and so the way I write I don't know how you guys write but the way I write is I start going forward from character and I start working backward from just shit I want to see and then and then there's all the middle bit where I get the characters into the places that I want to see right no way really that's pretty much fascinating yeah that is fascinating sometimes I felt like mature which was doing that unrest development he'd think up like the most genius sort of crazy stuff you just write backwards and make a plausible that we would arrive at that point yeah exactly well if you know you're ending you can just write the
whole thing right yeah so now I want to just we gotta let you go like in just a couple minutes but and I'm sorry to go way back but I did have tons of questions about the ocean and I knew because I'm I think it's just as fascinating as space I don't ever want to go down the ocean I mean it scares the shit out of me but because I've seen too many movies I do I just I can't swim so there's a whole thing hang on what do I know that that I can't swim well I went to the ocean with you a couple months ago but I but we only only went up to our waist like I don't want to go in but did we have we had this conversation you truly do not
know how to swim I don't kind of know how to swim no not really what and I'm colorblind okay so French bulldog you just go right to the bottom huh let's just all list all the stuff we can't do and our deficits well hang on I know I mean it'll be so cathartic it'll be so cathartic they named the Rolex watch out of him he goes so deep you know I mean okay wait a minute I do have this question so because I read in in anticipation of this I don't know the story I read that you took a chicken in a cage when you went down to the bottom when you did that long thing a yb what happened oh a dead chicken not a live
我会游泳吗？我其实不怎么会游泳。不，其实不会。什么？而且我有色盲。好吧，所以法国斗牛犬，你直接沉到底部对吧？让我们把所有我们不会做的事情和我们的缺陷都列出来吧。等等，我觉得这会非常宣泄，这会非常宣泄。他们用他的名字命名了劳力士手表，他潜得那么深，你知道我的意思吗？好吧，等一下，我确实有这个问题，因为我在为此做准备时读过——我不知道这个故事——我读到当你潜到水底、做那件长期的事情时，你带了一只笼子里的鸡。那是什么？哦，是一只死鸡，不是活的。
chicken yeah now it was just a chicken right you know like a like a broiler from why did he need the cage it was he was outside the sub he was actually on a robotic lander and it was just in a wire Frank why do I feel so persecuted here I want to know I want to know what was the result did because we wanted to film this sucker getting ripped apart by these these little amphipods that live down there that are like like the deep ocean piranha and in a like a like a five-minute time-lapse they come in and strip it to the bone so if you've ever you know you've ever seen a burial at sea you know with the flag and the guy
鸡，对。现在它只是一只鸡，你知道的，就像一只烤鸡。为什么他需要那个笼子？它在潜水器外面，实际上是在一个机器人着陆器上，它只是在一个铁丝网里。为什么我觉得在这里受到了迫害？我想知道，我想知道结果是什么，因为我们想拍摄这个倒霉蛋被那些生活在那里的、像深海食人鱼似的小端足类动物撕碎的画面，在大约五分钟的延时摄影中，它们会过来把它啃得精光。所以如果你曾经看过海葬，你知道的，有国旗和那个家伙
goes out from under the flag he's a skeleton in about 20 minutes now can ask you can ask you why how did you arrive at a chicken did you just think well they're gonna freak out because they've never they never smelt or tasted anything from land in other words like why did you use a dead fish they'd ripped out of part two would you think chicken oh they're gonna love this they they'll eat anything they don't care because the proof the protein for them is like manna from heaven it just falls from above there's nothing really mutt that's very big down where they live and they just scavenge on whatever falls
从国旗下面滑出来，大约20分钟后他就变成了一具骷髅。现在，我能问你吗？你怎么会想到用鸡？你是不是觉得它们会吓一跳，因为它们从来没有闻到或尝过任何来自陆地上的东西？换句话说，你为什么不用一条死鱼，它们也会把它撕成碎片？还是你会想：“鸡，它们会喜欢这个的，它们什么都吃，它们不在乎”，因为对它们来说蛋白质就像天降的甘露，它就是从天而降的？它们居住的地方下面真的没有什么很大的东西，它们只是靠任何掉落的东西为生。
out so sometimes it could be a whale or a dolphin or a fish or whatever I don't think they're very picky I read some occasional human you know sure or two or heaven help Sean Hayes if he ever gets out there he'll be right down there you're just hanging outside my door you have a pool at your house yeah how do you not swim I know like I doggy pat I'm gonna tell you that Jason I will pull together we're gonna put we're gonna get you some swim lessons you're gonna hold me up yeah Jim what what do you think at the when it's when you're all when you're done with all of this and because you've done so much that the
所以有时可能是一头鲸鱼、一只海豚、一条鱼或其他什么。我觉得它们不太挑剔。我读到过偶尔也会有人类，你知道的，当然。或者天佑肖恩·海斯，如果他曾经去过那里，他就会直接落到那里。你只是挂在我门外，你家有游泳池，对吧？你怎么不会游泳？我知道，就像狗刨一样。我要告诉你，杰森，我们会齐心协力的，我们要带你去上几节游泳课，你要支持我。是的。吉姆，当这一切都结束的时候，考虑到你做了那么多……
breadth of which is really pretty astonishing whether it's filmmaking or all this ocean oceanic stuff etc etc what do you want to be remembered for what do you what do you what's your legacy because it's pretty remarkable I'm still trying to figure out what I want to be when I grow up I love that yeah you could qualify for a bunch of legacy things there what if you had to pick one I'm I think look Explorer filmmaker storyteller I think it explores a storyteller you go you go someplace and you come back and you tell the story right yeah so a documentary filmmakers a storyteller you know
其广度确实相当惊人，无论是电影制作还是所有这些海洋学的东西等等，你希望被人们记住什么？你希望你的……你的传奇是什么？因为这相当引人注目。我还在努力弄清楚当我长大了我想做什么。我喜欢这个。是的，你可以为一堆传奇事物获得资格。如果你必须选择一个呢？我……我想看：探险家、电影制作人、故事讲述者。我认为探险家就是故事讲述者。你去某个地方，然后回来，讲这个故事，对吧？是的，所以纪录片制作人是一个故事讲述者，你知道，
a scripted filmmakers a storyteller you know I don't know I mean I do I have to choose why don't know they'll do it believe me but it is it is really remarkable you haven't you discovered a species or two as well perhaps yeah yeah yeah really yeah yeah yeah well you you you see a lot of stuff no one's ever seen when you get down there I'll bet yeah mostly small mostly small stuff but but definitely you know Sigourney weaver said once she's you know because of all your diving she said they as a cast kept thinking I hope he survives to make another movie that's saying that's saying thinking about her career again I can't
有剧本的电影制作人是一个故事讲述者，你知道，我不知道，我的意思是，我非得选择吗？我不知道，他们会的，相信我。但它确实……确实很了不起，你还发现了一两个物种，也许吧？是的，是的。真的吗？是的，是的。好吧，你……当你潜到我敢打赌你到底下时，你会看到很多从未有人见过东西。大多是小东西，但绝对是……西格妮·韦弗曾经说过，你知道，因为你所有的潜水，她说他们作为演员一直觉得“我希望他能活下来再拍一部电影”。那是……那是……再次想想她的职业生涯，我无法
imagine how difficult it must be to make your deal on all this stuff it must be so complicated I was just thinking about the lawyers of it all oh you just the risky things that he does I love the part that where they tell me I can't fly in a private plane or a helicopter and they forget to put that I can't take a sub seven miles down yeah that's my point is like you do all this stuff it's super risky and also like in the technology is proprietary and it's stuff that you're coming up with and you're you're like hey man we were what happened today like your kids might be like dad what'd you do while we were
想象你的生意要做成所有这些事情会有多难。一定非常复杂。我刚刚在想这一切背后的律师。哦，只是他所做的那些冒险的事情。我喜欢他们告诉我不能坐私人飞机或直升机的那部分，而他们却忘了加上我不能坐潜水器下潜七英里。是的，这就是我的意思，就像你做所有这些事情，超级危险，而且技术是专有的，这是你想出来的东西，你会说：“嘿，老兄，我们……今天发生了什么？”就像你的孩子们可能会问：“爸爸，我们在的时候你做了什么？”
shooting some stuff and I discovered three new species and I built a submarine the kids my kids couldn't care less is that I do during the day now how old are your kids what are the ranges 15 18 21 29 and 34 so but the teenagers they couldn't care less whatever whatever your parents are doing is not interesting by definition yeah no Jason and I know we have teenagers and they just couldn't I have a 14 they don't get away he has a 50 15 16 16 now your old girl our kids just do not care they're so non-plus humble yeah yeah god well you are the king of the world you really are you're a mark yeah until I walk in the front
拍了一些东西，我发现了三个新物种，我还造了一艘潜水艇。我的孩子们根本不在乎我在白天做什么。现在，你的孩子们多大了？年龄范围是多少？15、18、21、29和34岁。但是青少年们根本不在乎。无论你的父母在做什么，根据定义，这都是不有趣的。是的，不，杰森和我，你知道，我们有青少年，他们根本不……我有一个14岁的，他们没有离开。他有一个15、16、16岁的。现在你家的大女孩，我们的孩子们根本不在乎，他们太淡然了、太谦逊了。是的，上帝，好吧，你是世界之王，你真的是，你是一个标志……
door yeah exactly and every house put yours truly it's has been such a huge huge honor to meet you and listen to all of this today it's just I you are such a pivotal part of my childhood and my adulthood and just I just think you're incredible so you're 52 I'm 68 don't don't put that on you are though but I was growing up and I was like I would watch those over and by the way I can't not want by the you know my age more than my own father does but the but I can't believe yeah we got somebody we'd like to put in a submarine actually speaking of that I can do it yeah that's true I'm not gonna say that you're part of my
直到我走进前门。是的， exatamente（没错）。而且每栋房子都是……除了你自己的。非常荣幸能见到你并聆听今天的所有这一切。我只是……你是我童年和成年生活中如此关键的一部分，我只是觉得你不可思议。所以你52岁？我68岁。别……别把那个压在我身上。你确实是。但我当时正在长大，就像我会看那些……顺便说一句，我不能不看……你知道的，我比我自己的父亲更在乎我的年龄。但是……但是……我不敢相信……是的，我们有人想把他放进潜水艇里。事实上，说到这个，我可以做到。是的，那是真的。我不打算说你是我的……
child I'm gonna say you're a tremendous peer I like consider you a peer I've had a good time hanging out with you guys say it's been great well thank you for doing thank you for all your hard work yeah you're remarkable you're a remarkable artist and adventurer and thank you for everything all right cool yeah this has been great with the film can't wait to see it all right thank you thank you all right take care all right back to the mix pretty cool wow you know what I kept thinking though is like it's just a testament to his tenacity to just believe and so that's why I asked that long-winded question about like how
童年。我要说你是一个了不起的同辈。我把你当成同辈。我和你们一起度过了一段美好的时光，太棒了。好吧，谢谢你们做这些，谢谢你们所有的辛劳。是的，你太卓越了。你是一位杰出的艺术家和冒险家，谢谢你所做的一切。好的，酷。是的，这太棒了。关于这部电影，等不及要看了。好的，谢谢你们。谢谢。好的，保重。好的，回到混音，太酷了。哇，你知道我一直在想的是，这证明了他有着无比的韧性，能够去相信，所以这就是为什么我问了那个冗长的问题，关于如何……
do you not go just kidding like when when the when the dollar amount gets to remember when Titanic was the most expensive film ever made yeah and then Avatar was these two probably are I mean how does he convince when it gets like 200 million dollars which is what Titanic was at the time you was it how are you not like okay never mind just kidding like and then it was the first one to make a billion yeah right yeah what a roll the dice over and over and over again but then like you know you do something like Avatar and you you you he spawns like ancillary thing like a blue man group you know or think I'll
你怎么能不只是开玩笑呢？当……当金额达到——还记得《泰坦尼克号》是有史以来最昂贵的电影吗？是的。然后《阿凡达》是……这两部可能都是。我的意思是，当它达到2亿美元时——也就是《泰坦尼克号》当时的花费——你怎么能不觉得“好吧，算了吧，开玩笑的”？然后它是第一部票房突破十亿美元的电影。是的，对吧？真是反复不断地孤注一掷！但随后，你知道的，你做了一些像《阿凡达》这样的事情，你……他催生了一些辅助性的东西，比如蓝人乐团，你知道的，或者我想……
actually blue man group inspired avatar no they did what I was really hoping I would get you on that one wait what for two seconds I was like I don't remember reading that imagine if they just tried to sue Jim tell me but the part is even when they testify they don't say anything they're just drumming and shit and they keep suppose Mitch didn't give that line to David Cross and arrested like while he's all made up in the blue stuff he went in red for avatar I mean I think that there's some people are just wired differently and he is just he's just wired in a different way so did you ever see do you ever see the making of the
其实蓝人乐团是受《阿凡达》启发而诞生的。不，他们不是！我当时真的很希望我能在这点上把你套进去。等等，什么？有那么两秒钟，我觉得“我不记得读到过那个”。想象一下，如果他们试图起诉吉姆。告诉我，但最妙的是，即使他们作证，他们什么也不说，他们只是在打鼓什么的，而且他们一直……梅奇没有把那句台词给《发展受阻》里的大卫·克罗斯，当他浑身涂满蓝色颜料时，他为《阿凡达》涂成了红色？我的意思是，我认为有些人天生就是不一样的，他就是……他就是以一种不同的方式运转的。所以你有没有看过……你有没有看过……
abyss or have you ever seen the abyss no yeah I love the abyss you got it I've seen the making of it like five times it's it's mind-blowing that he built this tank and then they forgot to put salt in it so it was all fuzzy or something like that and so then they had a it was problem after problem after problem for a year and a half two years and they only had so much time to breathe under water and then they couldn't see the faces so they put lights in the helmets and it was just not yeah the amount of knowledge he has to have like from from computer technology to like engineering to I mean just I don't know how you get it all in
《深渊》的幕后花絮？或者你看过《深渊》吗？没有。是的，我喜欢《深渊》。你看过它的幕后花絮五次。这太令人震撼了，他建造了这个水箱，然后他们忘了在里面放盐，所以水质都很模糊什么的，然后他们就得……这是一个又一个又一个的问题，持续了一年半、两年，他们水下呼吸的时间非常有限，然后他们看不清脸，所以他们在头盔里装了灯，这简直……是的。他必须掌握的知识量，从计算机技术到工程学，我的意思是……我不知道你是怎么把所有这些都塞进去的。
there but Jay you know it's funny you say that I think that part of it must be that he's willing to to take a risk and he's willing to make a mistake mm-hmm yeah do you know what I mean like he's not nervous he didn't get it first try right stuff he came up with it would be trial and error and he seems to be the kind of guy who's has the confidence to go like yeah I don't know how to do it but we're gonna figure it out yeah that's and there's something there's a real lesson in that because we're all I I know I am you get nervous you have those moments where you're like I I don't want to fuck up or I don't want to look
但是，杰、你知道，你这么说很有趣，我想其中一部分一定是他愿意承担风险，他愿意犯错误。嗯哼。是的，你知道我的意思吗？他并不紧张，他没有在第一次尝试时就弄懂对吧？他想出的东西将是通过反复试验，他似乎是那种有信心说“是的，我不知道该怎么做，但我们会想办法解决的”的人。是的，那……这其中有一个真正的教训，因为我们所有人——我知道我是这样——你都会紧张，你会有那些时刻，你会觉得“我不想搞砸”或者“我不想看起来……”
stupid or whatever and truly you know creating great things comes out of these you know if you have the frame of mind of like I'm willing to fall on my face yeah and being able to be convincing and yeah articulate your your vision your plan and and lead yeah he's he's clearly one of our best I guess what if the Y was an I in that movie title oh here it comes get ready get ready well what would it would be I don't know what do you mean we'll be called the up by they're always the worst I know always just terrible because he always wants to go to buy and switch switch it's the same way that he
愚蠢“或者别的什么。而且确实，你知道，伟大的事物来自于这些……你知道，如果你有这样一种心态：“我愿意摔个狗吃屎”，并且能够有说服力、能够清晰地表达你的愿景、你的计划并进行领导。是的，他显然是我们最好的人之一。我想，如果那部电影片名里的“Y”变成了“I”会怎么样？哦，来了，准备好，准备好。好吧，那会……那会是……我不知道，你是什么意思？那会被叫做“The Up By”。它们总是最糟糕的。我知道，总是那么糟糕。因为他总是想买然后转换……就像他转换话题一样，说变就变。我们刚刚聊到正题，我们正在对话，我们正在结束关于不可思议的吉姆·卡梅伦的讨论，而你……吉姆·卡梅伦提到了鸡……
switched subjects just on a dime we're just getting somewhere we're having a conversation we're wrapping up talking about the incredible Jim camera and you and Jim camera mention mention chicken the ocean chicken in the ocean and you're like hey I gotta go find a deep-fried chicken somewhere you're just thinking about a bobbing chicken I had so many ocean questions I want that animator to do Jim taking a chicken down into the end down to do it seven right all right well listen happy Saturday happy Saturday love to you and yours is that by are we did we did we buy it out I think we I buy we abyssed we
海洋里的鸡。然后你就像：“嘿，我得去别的地方找个炸鸡吃吃。”你满脑子都是一只上下颠簸的鸡。我有太多关于海洋的问题了，我真想让那个动画师画一画吉姆带着一只鸡潜到最底部、下潜到七英里深处的画面！好吧，听着，祝你周六愉快，周六愉快，代我向你和你的家人问好。就这样？我们……我们买下了吗？我想我们买下了……我们“深渊”了……
have be we abysed listen I didn't think it was the greatest sign off but you know what I'm by yes that's just as bad what we've what we've done for the audiences we've done our own audio documentary on the making of a bite is that work smart smart less smart less smart less is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by Bennett Barbaco Michael Grant Terry and Rob I'm JARF smart loss our next episode will be out in a week wherever you listen to podcasts or you can listen to it right now early on Amazon music or early and add free by subscribing to Wondery Plus in Apple podcasts or the Wondery app There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们“深渊”了。听着，我认为这不是最棒的收尾，但你知道吗，我“深渊”了。这同样糟糕。我们为听众所做的是，我们制作了自己的关于制作“A Bite”的音频纪录片。那样行吗？聪明，聪明，更聪明，更聪明。SmartLess 是由班奈特·巴巴科、迈克尔·格兰特、特里和罗布100%有机且手工制作的。我是贾夫。SmartLess 的下一期节目将在下周发布，无论你在哪里听播客，都可以立即在亚马逊音乐上抢先收听，或者通过在苹果播客或 Wondery 应用上订阅 Wondery Plus 来抢先收听且无广告。这个剧集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任何句子即可发表评论。